künstliche intelligenz ist so ziemlich
die technologie der zukunft es gibt kaum
ein großes unternehmen konsortium oder
hochschule das gerade nicht mit
hochdruck an künstlicher intelligenz
forscht um ganz vorne mit dabei zu sein
vorbild und zielmarke sind dabei oft die
überlegene leistungsfähigkeit des
biologischen gehirns aber das ist auch
eine menge arbeit ein entwicklerteam in
australien will sich deswegen die
mühselige entwicklungsarbeit sparen und
direkt hirnzellen in computer einbauen
es klingt vielleicht im ersten moment
verrückt doch ihr erster prototyp lernt
schon jetzt schneller als künstliche
intelligenz von normalen computern wie
sie das gemacht haben genau darum geht
es in diesem video
[Musik]
biologische intelligenz löst genau die
aufgaben die der künstlichen intelligenz
das meiste kopfzerbrechen bereiten denn
seit über 800 millionen jahren trennt
die evolution tier und mensch darauf in
echtzeit unbekannte situationen zu
erfassen und entscheidungen zu treffen
denn das sichert das überleben der
ursprung biologisch intelligenz ist die
selbstständige vernetzung von neuronen
jede hirnzellen kommuniziert über
tausende von verbindungen mit anderen
neuronen und jeder einzelne dieser
verbindungen kann ein neuron aufbauen
abbauen verstärken oder abschwächen so
passt das gehirn sich flexibel an neue
situationen an und lernt gleichzeitig
aus erfahrungen und das ganz ohne
software hardware und speicherbänke denn
all diese funktionen stecken schon in
der biologie der neuronen drin die
nervensysteme die so entstehen sind
extrem komplex aber auch robust
leistungsstark und effizient und genau
diese eigenschaften wollen informatiker
schon seit den 50er jahren nachahmen sie
erfanden auto fischl networks für die
viele kleine recheneinheiten miteinander
verbunden sind aber das simulieren
komplexer netzwerke mit rechenmaschinen
ist schwierig es sollte jahrzehnte
dauern bis es prozessoren und speicher
gab die der aufgabe halbwegs gerecht
wurden und die künstlichen neuronalen
netzwerke ihren siegeszug antreten
konnten heute sind die pure networks
praktisch synonym mit künstlicher
intelligenz aber trotz allem machen sie
den biologischen vorbild noch immer kaum
konkurrenz und man arbeitet weiter daran
aufzuholen wie enforcement learning ein
lern prinzip von mensch und tier dass
ich euch hier schon mal erklärt habe
ermöglicht einer künstlichen intelligenz
zu lernen entscheidungen zu treffen zum
beispiel kann es spiele erlernen einfach
wenn die musi spielt auf der
hardwareseite entwickelt man so genannte
no more für prozessoren sind prozessoren
die anders als die bisher genutzten
konventionellen gps informationen
mittels kurzer spannungsspitzen
kommunizieren sowie neuronen es tun
davon erhofft man sich dass künstliche
neuronale netzwerke sparsamer und
schneller werden zusammengefasst mann
betreibt einen riesigen aufwand um
künstliche neuronale netzwerke den
biologischen immer ähnlicher zu machen
hängt dabei aber noch weit hinterher
zumindest in den meisten bereichen aber
moment mal könnte man sich diesen ganzen
aufwand nicht sparen und stattdessen
gleich einfach ein biologisches netzwerk
an einen computer anschließen das klingt
nach krasser science fiction aber genau
das versucht aktuell eine firma in
australien zunächst stellt sich
natürlich die frage sind gehirn und
computer überhaupt kompatibel
auf der einen seite haben wir ein
logisch konstruiertes rechnungssystem
mit software hardware und
speicherplätzen implementiert mit
transistor technologie ein computer ist
gemacht um rechenoperationen auszuführen
auf der anderen seite haben wir ein
organisch wachsen das geflecht aus
neuronen in den grenzen zwischen
software hardware und speicher einfach
nicht existieren nervensystem haben sich
entwickelt um schnell komplexe
entscheidungen zu treffen und sie
umzusetzen
während also ein computer problemlos mit
großen zahlen rechnet habe ich probleme
allein schon vierstellige zahlen im kopf
zu multiplizieren dafür kann ich
gleichzeitig gehen und reden ohne dass
ich mein gehirn an einem haus großen
super computer anschließen muss
vielleicht gibt es aber auch einige von
euch die nicht nur gleichzeitig gehen
und reden sondern ein rad fahren und
dabei mit fackeln jonglieren während sie
auf einem drahtseil über eine schlucht
balancieren es klingt nach einem
spannenden aber auch echt riskanten
hobby bei dem eine passende
unfallversicherung sicher nicht schaden
kann und damit kommen jetzt im sponsor
des heutigen videos klar ich persönlich
finde dass sich erstmal jeder ganz
unabhängig mit seinen versicherungen
auseinandersetzen sollte denn sie können
in einem auf der einen seite mega den
arsch retten hier schon mehrfach
passiert aber auf der anderen seite auch
eine menge geld kosten clark ist ein
digitaler versicherungsmanager direkt
fürs handy der euch dabei unterstützen
kann einen überblick über eure ganzen
versicherungen zu behalten in der cloud
könnt ihr nachsehen was ihr im jahr so
zahlt und was eure versicherungen alles
abdecken oder eben auch was sie nicht
abdecken wenn ihr das möchte dann kann
clark euch mit ausgebildeten
versicherungsmaklern dabei helfen zu
überprüfen wo ihr vielleicht noch einmal
nachjustieren sollte und was vielleicht
unnötig ist ihr können über die app aber
auch schadensmeldungen durchgeben oder
euch über kündigungsfristen alter
verträge benachrichtigen lassen eine
sache die ich an dieser stelle noch
einmal betonen möchte ist dass ihr mit
dem einrichten von clark auch ein makler
mandat abschließt und das ist wichtig
das bedeutet dass clark in euren namen
neue versicherungen abschließen und alte
kündigen kann natürlich immer mit eurer
zustimmung das vereinfacht zum einen
vieles weil clark euch so unabhängig
beraten kann es kann aber auch dazu
führen dass eurem aktuellen makler das
mandat entzogen wird solltet ihr also
bereits eine person haben mit der wir
das thema versicherungen angeht dann
spricht das auf jeden fall vorher mit
dieser person ab das mandat kann dann
natürlich jederzeit widerrufen und euer
konto auch wieder geschlossen werden
klickt gerne auf den ersten link unten
in der video beschreibung um euch noch
weiter zu informieren und mit dem kot
watson alles groß geschrieben könnt ihr
euch mit jeder hochgeladenen
versicherungen einen 50 euro
einkaufsgutschein bis zu maximal 45 euro
sichern und unterstützt aber auch noch
uns und diesen kanal hier und weitere
spannende videos vielen dank aber trotz
der großen gegensätze kann eine
verbindung von gehirn und maschine
funktionieren stichwort brain machine
interfaces auch dazu gibt es schon ein
video von uns auf dem kanal
gehirnzellen kommunizieren über
aktionspotenziale also kurze
spannungsimpulse wir können
aktionspotenziale messen und wir können
sie auch auslösen indem wir ganz kurz
von außen eine kleine spannung an gegen
beides lesen und stimulieren geht mit
denselben elektroden jetzt schließen wir
noch einen computer für die auswertung
und steuerung der neuronalen aktivität
an und fertig ist die schnittstelle ganz
einfach aber obwohl schon lange andrei
machine interfaces geforscht wird hat es
bisher nur das cochlea implantat in die
breite anwendung geschafft es gibt aber
auch experimentelle systeme mit deren
hilfe versuchsteilnehmer prothesen
steuern können zb einen roboterarm auch
ihre maske nur link arbeitet an einem
brain machine interface das natürlich
irgendwann mal alles können soll zum
beispiel kann dieser affe hier damit
meint morgen spielen die verbindung aus
gehirn und maschine kann also
funktionieren aber die forscherinnen und
forscher wollen ein isoliertes
biologisches netzwerk in einen computer
ein baum nicht das ganze gehirn das wäre
overkill und auch sehr schwierig und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen unethisch
[Musik]
platt gesagt man will gehirnzellen in
einen motherboard stecken wie eine neue
grafikkarte dazu muss man sie erstens
auf einem kleinen kontrollierbaren raum
unterbringen und dann zweitens dafür
sorgen dass sie sich optimal an die
schnittstelle eines computers anpassen
dazu eignen sich mutti elektrode race
das sind platinen mit dutzenden bis
hunderten von kontaktstellen auf diesen
platinen kann man flache präparate
aufbringen höheren schnitte zum beispiel
oder eine netzhaut hirn schnitte ist bei
baic waren sie milch schnitte für
zombies that really eine lebende
scheiben geschnitten hirn
während des versuchs wird das
empfindliche gewebe auf der richtigen
temperatur gehalten und mit einer
nährlösung überspült die auch sauerstoff
an die zellen heranbringt mit solchen
apparaten haben neurowissenschaftler
unglaublich viel über die funktionsweise
von neuronen herausgefunden die vorhin
beschriebenen präparate stammen leider
immer noch von tieren die dafür ihr
leben lassen müssen aber auch für dieses
ethische probleme hat die moderne
wissenschaft eine lösung und das sind
pluripotente stammzellen die kann man
aus embryos von tieren entnehmen oder
noch besser man stellt sie aus
hautzellen eines erwachsenen menschen
her so dass gar keine tiere mehr am
prozess beteiligt sind mit der richtigen
behandlung werden aus diesen stammzellen
dann neuronen die kann man anschließend
auf ein multi elektronen ray aufbringen
und die richtige elektrische stimulation
steuert anschließend ihr wachstum und
genau so funktioniert das system das die
australische firma korte collapse
modifiziert hat um biologische
intelligenz in computing zu integrieren
und ihre erfindung nennen sie die spreng
wie ihr vielleicht schon gemerkt habt
ein standard an dem man lernende systeme
gerne testet ist der audi der
computerspiele und genau daran hat auch
das forscherteam in australien sein
system getestet damit unser
zweidimensionales mini cyborg höheren
hong spielen kann braucht es eine art
display und die möglichkeit eingaben zu
machen das display ist ein rechteckiger
bereich auf der platine der
grundsätzlich so funktioniert wie ein
kleiner bildschirm nur dass keine pixel
auf leuchten sondern elektroden neuronen
stimulieren die eingabe funktioniert
ähnlich die forschenden haben bereiche
definiert in denen die neuronale
aktivität gemessen und gemittelt wurde
waren die zellen in einem der bereiche
aktiv bewegte sich das paddle nach oben
waren sie in einem anderen bereich aktiv
dann bewegt es sich nach unten als
feedback für einen verpassten bei
simulierten die forscher einfach kurz
alle neuronen gleichzeitig das war das
erste mal dass man das überhaupt
versucht hat und nicht nur hat es
funktioniert der mini cyborg hat sich
auch gar nicht so schlecht angestellt in
gerade mal ein paar minuten hat das
kleine netzwerk aus hirnzellen begonnen
pong zu lernen dabei performte ein
system mit menschlichen hirnzellen erst
schlechter als eines mit 15 von einer
maus lernte dann aber schneller und
performte am ende besser mega spannend
und wie ich finde unglaublich gras beide
biologischen systeme erlernten pong mit
weniger spielwiederholungen als
künstliche neuronale netzwerke eines
klassischen computers der computer kann
aber wohl am ende erst mal doch noch
besser spielen allerdings sprechen wir
hier von nur wenigen hundert neuronen
ein mensch besitzt rund 86 milliarden
hirnzellen die skalierungsmöglichkeiten
sind hier also riesig und das letzte
wort zur performance noch lange nicht
gesprochen die autoren erwähnen immer
wieder dass die hirnzellen in die
virtuelle welt integriert sein das
netzwerk dachte es sei das paddle
beschrieb ist einer der autoren wohl
gegenüber einem journalisten
gemeint war dass das display die bald
position relativ zur mitte des panels
darstellte stadt so wie wir es beim
spielen sehen nach meinung unseres haus
neurowissenschaftler ist doktor denn das
eckmair vereinfachte dass das zu lösende
problem allerdings sehr ganz sicher
haben aber ein paar hundert zellen kein
bewusstsein schweige denn ein von selbst
oder ihre position in einer virtuellen
welt bisher ist das paper nur als
preprint zu finden das heißt ob die
studie bereits von unabhängigen experten
begutachtet wurde und in der aktuellen
form bald in einem offiziellen journal
erscheinen wird das wissen wir noch
nicht aber es haben sich schon einige
experten journalisten gegenüber positiv
geäußert die entwicklung von
biologischen neuronalen netzwerken als
bauteil in einem computersystem ist
natürlich noch ganz am anfang eine große
hürde ist der aufwand mit dem sie
hergestellt und betrieben werden
schließlich müssen die zellen aus
stammzellen gezüchtet und auf der
platine am leben gehalten werden in die
hosentasche wird man solche geräte
wahrscheinlich nicht stecken können aber
möglicherweise können sie ja eines tages
irgendwann mal in computing server
integriert werden auf die wir dann
vielleicht remote zugreifen können oder
sie stecken in autonomen robotern
schließlich haben sich biologische
neuronale netzwerke rtl gehirne genauso
entwickelt eine frage bleibt
unbeantwortet
wie löst ein netzwerk überhaupt ein
konkretes problem einen hirn oder auf
einen dieb nur network ist nämlich eine
blackbox man weiß was reingeht und man
weiß was rauskommt aber man weiß nicht
auf welche logik die problemlösung
basiert man kann die
entscheidungsfindung von so einer box
nicht überprüfen und korrigieren bevor
sie einen möglicherweise schwerwiegenden
fehler macht wollen wir also in zukunft
wichtige vielleicht lebenswichtige
entscheidungen systemen überlassen die
wir nicht komplett durchschauen und noch
etwas finde ich wichtig ab wann wird so
ein system aus dem biologischen
computerchips empfindungsfähigkeit
wickelt sogar ein bewusstsein
schließlich handelt es sich um
menschliche gehirnzellen schon heute
fragt man sich aus eben diesen gründen
ob es ethisch vertretbar ist großer
verbände aus neuronen manchmal auch
etwas optimistisch mini brains genannt
zu forschungszwecken zu züchten wurde
hier ein bewusstsein kreiert das black
mirror messe ich den ganzen tag für die
rest seines lebens punktspielen muss
wahrscheinlich nicht aber ab einer
gewissen menge neuronen könnte sich
möglicherweise ein bewusstsein
entwickeln dass gefühle und
selbstständige gedanken hat und das
sollten wir auf jeden fall vermeiden
schreibt mir gerne mal in die kommentare
was eure meinung zu einem computer chip
dieser art ist findet ihr das gut findet
ihr dass carey habt ihr angst dass da
ein bewusstsein entsteht wenn euch
videos wie dieses hier gefallen dann
überlegt euch doch mal ob wir uns auf
page und unterstützen wollt denn uns
hilft das auf jeden fall sehr und für
euch ist das auch praktisch denn ihr
könnt zum beispiel videos wie dieses
hier vor allen anderen seen oder ihr
bekommt zugriff auf unsere skripte und
können mal einen blick behind the scenes
werfen wie wir diese videos hier
kreieren schaut doch mal vorbei pagerank
von com / doktor watson gesagt uns hilft
es auf jeden fall mega und wie immer
viel dank fürs zuschauern bis zum
nächsten mal bleibt neugierig hattrick